の皆さんにお伝えしたいいやー
みんなの将来を社会の見られる
下げる真さん
そういう快挙の姉の子をしたいと思います
御存知3パターン
広進さん
かわいいですね
この方がいいですねまぁ見ての通り多い
浅見18歳今年からなん
いうことでパールイズミさプレートが英語の広さんは
イメージからカーン
ピットハさせる
それについての評判 pr 伝えた
ちょっと聞いてみましょうか
今日行っ者の皆さんの中で自分マッサージ93
あや葉巻状の角でも今行われている3人
この選挙が初めての投票の機会になっている方はどれがいらっしゃいます
多いですね上がらないん
はいご協力ありがとうございます
実は
この3000円にあたって
こんな
2つです
高精度に反感を買うようなところがいいと思います
日本の将来を決め銀行
おそらくですね今日は他の皆さんも即位しとして
役とか学校とか聴いてもらうとこの日本の将来を常に行こう
そういうタイトルねーよなポスターが貼ってある
考えございます
終え決めに行くって
なーん
例えば e
日本のと言われたときに
何があるのかなぁということでワーッと入りました
今回ません
ありゃまきんいち先生時のマンあるいは日本全体の中でいろいろ議論になっていること
話がタイプ
県民な話がありがとうございました
当然学生の皆さんへと変わるそういうような話肺膿瘍とかですねそういういろんな話が
日本のというところに扱ってると思う
さあ
日本の将来を
なんで将来を考え
今に千住
江幡は2020年保存一番一つマミーとなる古紙なっ
でも日本の将来を考えたときはそんなに二回しかんじゃなくて
ほんともとなく
こちら20代の方が五十代六十年話が80万
そんなことも含めて日本の将来宝庫
いう風に考えなければい
日本の将来を振り本ということを
選挙権を持った直後くらい持った時ぐらいの自分のことを思い浮かべて
幅4いまや日本のいろんなことあるいは将来て永井さん
したことごめーんばー
選挙権を持ったところもの
自分に聞いてみました
僕こんなもん勝ちだったんだねーと思った頃
こんな人間簡単ですけど気じゃねぇ
実は
僕自身が大学生の頃からは開局プロゴルファーよるカメラを矯正
あるいは改革制定の件が本当自慢遠投性
そういうことを色々考え活動をしてい
おそらく
お母ん次第でも政治のことに関心が使用量を考えまし
でもそんなものでもさっき出した4打点
あれはすごい長い期間を考えておきましょう
そういうことを考えた上で日本の将来を聞きに行けたかどうぞ
いうことを考えるとすごく美味しかった
わがまま日本の将来を決めにいける
例えばですね
こんな話を4妻ん
若い世代は今後に入ってる若い世代は
自分の次元将来
すごい先のことまで考えなあ
先までにパいろんな製作4な判断かんじゃないということが言われているんです
それって本当なん本当にまあハンマー日本の将来君に行ける
日本の将来は本当に考えことができる
弊社の話は版だけではない
それ
辛い得るまま高齢者
いろんな経験してです
いろんなしまういろんなことに生まれて来ましたところがあるん
じゃあ考案者の人なぁ
日本の将来を機にいう
お母さんを誓う
お空に駅あるいはゆよあるいは海外のかなということに関してはおそらく僕がちょっと
ですね
上の世代の方のほうがいろいろ考えていました
ありー
子育てしない
こっちに少し視点をずらしてみましょう
を超えます患者さんやん
ちょうどですね僕くらいねぇなるこう
周りの友達が結婚してい
子供を待ちます
そういう人はどうなんコーナーです
きゅうり政治の話ツイーターな場所特にいい子供がで1箇所か
今まで一回も公の兄あーまーどこも立ち
お子さんができて
まぁ全然一方政治と関わるからせる
あるいはたさんを本保スナックことがない国日本の将来
んなぁ
もちろんサービス内にとって言えばおそらく関わりを持っていうのは贈られる
感謝が誰かいるアブソ
でもですねあーもう恒例こそ13
間彼のような人たちの経験ペーパーで日本の将来を決め日本とってできないんじゃない
かなとか思う
僕が日本の将来を決めるという定義としては佐倉市いろんな課題が日本にあります
どんな問題があります
将来がすごいならば長いファンになりと見えないけど
それが本当に
僕らが金融の稼働ワープ
芋の葉
僕らはですねお酢1
考える反乱20をとって
自分の身の回り納得だ
自分のちょっとした将来
それぐらいは周りの気がするんですよね
学生なら学生 no
勉強の保管ん
バイブのございません
あるいは学生を卒業して就職をするというちょっとした障害になると思います
それぐらいしかですねも世代の立場の人がなかなか考えることができないんじゃないか
揺り動かされていん
ちょっと政治の仕組みの話を送りましょう
間接民主主義
ユーザー皆さんも聞いたことがあるかなと思ってます
山いいは品等が
皆さん一人一人が日本の政治のもと日本の将来の克服説明いるわけじゃない
僕たちが得られるのは青二鋼4
その選挙迷惑
最初に何か提供するのは選ばれて選手パ
あるいはが悪いかそれとも人たちで決めるん
あゆは戦後中です
気分や政治の場から広まっていただきます
悪性のかっ候補者が私たちはこういう擬音の将来を作るためにそういうことをやります
ここ日本裁判事てかここを改善してこういういます
そういうことは剥製も放射なくたちは提案で言えば縁で僕らんすタイプ
僕は宿泊に感謝でありますが最終的にすべてのホット変形してわけじゃないん
選挙で政治家であるその人たちから予算案 kokia
イラマ制作なった
それでも警備
をした昨日本の将来を決めているのは最終的に決めきるの僕らの政治家パン
だから雨に言えば
日本の全部あるいは将来の長いスパンなんて僕らは考えなきゃいけないん
でもやるソナー
僕らがに政治がば前につけているが最終的に決めるのは政治からそんな彼女と問屋
僕らはしてできること思っ
自分の身の前ないことと自分のちょっとした将来の事しかなかなか考えないんでしても
その考える範囲7でも広げきっ
そういうことを僕はうれしくしてやらなきゃいけないんじゃないか
やり方はいろいろあると思います
たとえ専門できるような本
そういうもの4ようなことを学んでいるような首位そういうことをやってみます
ありゃ毎日いろんな神 v龍ですね面白がほのちゃんといいグット出張いうことで
やっぱりいいかもしれん
でも正直ちょっと大変かと思うんですよね色んな専門商いろんなことを選んでクラム
ん
ではですねもうちょっとっ
気楽にやりやすい
あるいはこの pop がワーカーのこの統合を聞いた口すぐにできる自分の幅の広げ
かなということを伝えるゲームはなかった
かぎ編みしかなというところです
にしかな人らにしかのばカラー
多様な考えたような視点から前に知ってそれについても互いに励まし車
そういうことが自分の幅を広げるいます
日常の眺めしやすい最初のステップなんじゃないかなよくわかんないんです
たとえ
選挙権も18歳以上-3
このことをゲーム学校競馬がすごくカーン
僕自身も自分の活動の中でませんこの写真じゃないですね高校の現場に行って
を5000に誠実5いろんな治療を
呼ば事業も叱るのは模擬新曲呼ばれる事情です
角野
放射架空の生産中の何か2ですね
上がで作ってそれは今後1004
米もらって誰に投票するかを決めてもらえればもうに選曲プログラフスタッフいう
でもこれ別になるのですね僕の箱に票を入れるというこの行為を会見してもらう古墳は
プログラム北的には分からないん
ちょっと1でやらない1人の候補者を焼くという過程がいろいろなんです
あるいは自分が悩んでいることを捉えなコモダチかどういうふうに奈落
それが友達が同じ架空の政局を方みたく日にどういうことを感じている
それは働く知ってもらう場が美味しい9いうプログラムだと思う
今度やっぱたとえ
に行動したのかそこのはわー
お互い話をしたら絶望そ
すごくなんだよッ
訪韓北罰を常に一緒にいるんだってすごく仲の良い友達が全然違う放射逃げていること
があるんですね
あれなんか違う
それから知事ニャー
中身しいろんなことも死刑反対か改めてちょっと政治あるや政策のことを考えていると
前政権が違うん
そういうことをずっとタイミングはある
これは身近な人を改め話した時に言えると思います
いろんな考えを知っ
あるいは西浜
きっとどうしても
国の政治とかあるいは政治関係とどうしても国会
そういうことマーク思い浮かべることが多いのかなと思うんですが
20自分たちの町の話1
自分たちの街が臼歯にもこう全盛時のあるわけです
街の流れにいろんな課題いろんな面白世論な問題を踏まえ
ん
これは僕が空かそうなんですけれども
3階
5過去教員の流れというところ知ってるんですが東京の中の名機の周りで次に3回
くらいこんな写真うん
いろんな世代の人たちどんな式を放ち
いろんな人たちが集まってみんなで号黄色4支部という活動があったんです
ごめんなさいちょっとうそーせいかんでしょ
ゴミ拾いをしていい御門という活動約初です
面白いんです
b 飲んでるいろんな人達でビールを飲んでると自然刺青のかなり価値は言えばいい
です
いろんなちー者がの取得いろんな経験があるどんな人の興味を走ってる
そろそろ区学校現場もしれないと振り返った
学名はで高校3年生が3そこまで話す身近な人と話したこともあるし
でも身近な街の中に出て行って待ちということを系マリ
いろんな世代の話ですけどね
これもですね14自分の可用性自分の身の繭コーチの下ていくために
スパイ車
そしてですね座って自分が
a timer
頂からまし
そして台湾といろいろ話を知っ
でもそれらのせいじゃない
一緒に学ぶものでもなんか僕ら大物でもそんなまでもなくて僕が政治に関わる
いうことを考えたときに脳たような考えまして
あればいけないなぁ
そして考えタコ星人統計になった言葉は何か考える
落ちたら嫉妬悋気を講じるとやり方でしょこちらをそれも大事だと思います
やってほしい
でもなんかさせなければいけないです
いやー
アパザッツ人を選挙前へその議員にすべて任すしかないん
そんなのじゃ全くないわけです
何か選挙以外のことでも非なることがあれば
思い切って政治家の塾長日本を訪ねてもいいかもしれん
さすがにそれはハードラーじゃないなぁと思えば政治家のチーターにいくら飛ばして
みればいいん
皆さん住んでいる町のホームページでも見てみてくださ
おそらく方すべての町のホームページのどこバーン
視聴園を狙う
ある首相へのお答え
そんなものがありません
そこは順番を守っても変わらないということをそのホームから金曜するだけ
僕らの声が八先生事項を守られます
いろんな先生の解き方があるんだ
そういう事も僕らしくはもうちょっと一式を開け
選挙だけじゃないん
隠し外見を ok 他の意見を想像して
そして構えて件は
政治家が主役じゃない
政治家がさゆき見えるのかもしれないけど決める前に僕らしたような言い方で
いろいろなかなか様の意見を元に自分の考えを伝えるてくださいあなたがしちゃったん
それだけ
あなたが者って言うカーンとなりますと申し上げなんだって黒モグラ意識しているはず
です
自分の意見はこういうこともあれば止まりいるもう一人ちゃん人間の遠いことは
もちろんあるん
申します
たい話を広げてもらいましたん
中ある橋という冠を聞いた言葉
ある人もいると思います
山三姉妹まあ数多い
高齢世代機への世代の方たちの意見あるいは考えばどうも政治の中では住所されて威力
ありがとう次世代向けの政策になったり勝率ない向けの政策にかける予算の方が
若者向けの制作費や傘よりも実施されている
そういうことを主までに+トゥイータまで日本を言われています
でも僕ねこの芝での暮らしももう違うんじゃないかな
今回全部すごくおもしろくていっ
いろんな文系の制作だったらいいん
課題だった力のん
すごく増え
例えば奨学金の話をどうする
ブラックバイ飯書道を育て抜けるいろんなシーンを吸う
これでバーン ok な話ってすごく引いているわけですね
ただしここで気になるのは
世代だけ運慶の話になってないかなということが二飛になることとして細部をお伝えし
たい
今生きているあるいは選挙に行ける今声を上げる人向けのいろんな政策が行う
あるいは暗い女こっ
吉原までの声を届けられる人は届けてるわけなので
は分前ない
次の世代の人向けの話というのはあなたが出てこないわけです
を喰らう氏は
皆さんをそういう人頭から吊らますかっ
でも隣の人もしなくなったかます隣の人と話してみるん
あまりしないが見えないけど政治名前選挙の話をしてみよう
それ秋の話バイクの話オレもなくすごく大きいて難しければ
自分の身近な街ばここが好きなボクは嫌いでそういう話でていません
もう一つ考えないといけないのは
まだ話すことができないっ
まだ午前何もなければ主ことはできないけれども次の世代の主役なんだという事も僕ら
挙げて考えている
18歳真剣になってい
本当に若者と政治の反映
あるいはすごかの境目はへ政治と僕が一人一人皆さん一人一人の関係というのは変わっ
てくるきっかけに
この選挙が確実になっていいと思います
僕ランチャートップ意識をして
自分らしん
皆さん商材それは皆さん自身の将来ってだけじゃない皆さんの紹介がいろいろあさぬま
考えが集まることによって社会全体の
いや8サービング巨
そんな戦参加の方点を改めて考えて行きたいと思いますみなさんもう少し意識をして
歩道を起こして見ていただければ
確実に面白い愛が待ってるんじゃないかっ
そう思って最初も僕のアイディアとさせていただきます
どうもご静聴ありがとうございましたん